[Music]
book reviews back baby
yeah but you weren't expecting days me
neither i got back into reading some
fiction and i have a couple good uh
recommendations
yeah starting off with a stranger by
albert
camus
as i like to call him so i read this i
picked it up randomly and i
i was like this is so good i and i
recommend it to my mom and she's like
he's like no it's albeit kami
i'm like oh you know him he's like
oh he's a he's a famous writer everyone
knows him apparently except me he won
the nobel prize in literature so
it wasn't just some random book that i
found and thought wow what a treasure no
one's heard about this one
i feel like this kind of book you would
read in school maybe as well so maybe
some of you are familiar with this novel
already
the stranger follows the story of
marshall who is
this very strange guy i don't know how
to describe him exactly he just doesn't
look at the world in the same lens as
other people he's not evil by any means
but he
gets in all kinds of trouble because of
it and it makes it really funny i'm not
sure if it's i don't think it's supposed
to be funny but to me the whole concept
is really funny
uh but i don't want to explain it and
spoil it but it starts off with my mom
died today or yesterday maybe i don't
know i got a telegram from home mother
disease funeral tomorrow faithfully
yours that doesn't mean anything maybe
it was yesterday so you follow along the
story of marcel he gets involved in the
murder i'm not sure if that's spoiling
too much
uh
and all the details of all the events
that leads up to before everything that
goes down it all has a purpose in the
end and that's what really really made
me appreciate just how tight this novel
is
a lot of times you read read books and
they can kind of go in menu details of
things that doesn't seem important
but it all has a purpose in this novel
which i really really appreciate it when
it all comes together it highlights the
absurdity of us trying to find justice
order and rationale
behind our lives i don't know
it's a
it's a short read it's it's entertaining
if you haven't read a book in a while
and want to get back into it i think
this is a great place to start i loved
it so much i read the his other
works the plague as well which is uh
equally amazing but i don't want to hear
more about plagues i don't want to hear
more about these virus things no thank
you i don't know why i went through that
but it's shockingly accurate anyhow
check that out as well next i read
dante's inferno yeah i started this a
while ago but i never finished it and uh
what a shame that would have been
because this is an amazing book you've
probably heard about this as well
dante's inferno is quite famous it has a
video game made of it i'm not sure how
accurate that is but it's the story of a
man going through all the layers of hell
hell is divided into these sections
depending on
how bad you were in your life i think i
started reading it and then in the first
layer there's all the philosophers i'm
like what is this command it's an
incredible journey and you really feel
like you're part of part for the ride
the main character is
goes through hell with a guide and it's
sort of an outside perspective
and he can interact with the people in
hell he can speak to them
understanding their stories their
tragedies of why they're there what
their reaction to being in hell is this
is really interesting and very immersive
to
to go on this journey literally through
hell starting off with yeah the lesser
crimes like the philosophers want
believers or worshipers i assume uh to
then the the final layer where the devil
himself chills out i think uh marseille
read this because it's an italian writer
don't they and whether you are religious
or not if you're interested in this
concept of going through hell i think i
think definitely pick it up it's really
good don't quote me on these things i
saw someone make like a here's what
pewdiepie thinks of this book it's
really good
cool glad i could help glad i couldn't
contribute listen i'm just saying it's
really good
[Music]
i'm not a writer okay next up i read uh
our mathematical universe by max stigma
i love this book it's so good it's
really good
this book is basically everything in
physics that is cool that's what i
learned about the doomsday theory i
never heard about that before and i just
thought whoa that's so interesting uh he
speaks about multi multi-layered
universe which to me i was so sure was
just a sci-fi concept that has no
actual foot in science but turns out no
it does
and if you want to explain around it you
have to come up with all these other new
new rules of physics which makes it
really awkward so it kind of blew my
mind i had a bit of a rick and morty uh
moment reading this if you're interested
in physics or cosmology this is a
definitely check this out max is a
swedish writer so maybe i'm a little
biased but did i say i read his i
reviewed his other work life 3.0 but i
actually like this one even more which i
didn't expect he explained that he
didn't like physics when he was younger
because he just thought it was kind of
pointless with learning about density
and friction
i can understand that physics for me was
always the
subject that i thought was boring but i
always did veteran and i never
understood why this is pointless but
whatever but i always thought it was
interesting this is learning how our
world works even even if it is kind of
lame
ain't nothing lame in this though this
is all the like i said cool things about
physics and cosmology because max
actually contributed to a lot in
cosmology or measuring the cosmic what
was it called radiation background cmd
cmd osmic
microwave background which i didn't know
what it was
the oldest radiation in our universe
approved for big bang so max isn't just
some random guy interested in this stuff
he actually he's actually renowned in
the field and he's giving these sort of
personal details of how these
experiments took place and
stories he's heard from other scientists
and it's this really fun bonus to read
and learn about i'll definitely make
more videos of stuff that i learned in
this book because i just find it so
fascinating i almost feel like i'm naive
for just like buying into it because
but it has an actual bearing in science
and i think that's the whole thing that
he talks about how cosmology used to not
been taken seriously because a lot of
theories were just so outrageous but now
it actually has a better footing so to
say reading a lot of stuff in this book
kind of makes me feel like how people
felt i don't know maybe this is stupid
but back in the day when you learned
that the earth wasn't the center of the
universe you know you learned these sort
of truths about our universe that
which is kind of daunting you almost go
no that can't be right no way other
universes no nah
that's that's too weird this is a lot of
weird stuff in here which makes it
really fun and exciting uh max is also
self-admittedly a little bit crazy and
he he just goes
sicko mode the last chapters which i
really appreciated about his own
theories uh about what the universe
actually is which i thought yeah is
really fun i should have mentioned this
earlier but what really makes this book
so uh great is the fact that he can
explain these really complicated uh
concepts like quantum theory and yeah
multi-universe and all that and you can
actually follow along i'm not sure how
much you understood really but you know
i enjoyed it you know that tweet that
ninja made that was so funny like i
can't stop thinking about time alternate
realities infinite universes that is
constantly expanding that's me i feel
you ninja you read this book and you're
like i can't stop
and lastly
love this bug
who would the [ __ ] would pick this up
another random pickup i've been
literally just going on goodreads and
they've been recommending me some bomb
ass bugs this book is
i love it i love this book read this
book it's great you'll feel great
reading it
it's the story of siddhartha uh
siddhartha i didn't know this but that's
the that was the name of buddha before
he
became buddha he was prince siddhartha
it's the story of his life basically he
started off as an as a training monk i
guess you could call it and he's very
successful at it but he comes to a point
where he decides
i don't want to be taught anything else
what i need is experience so he goes out
in life like a normal person would and
interacts with relationship
with with money and with friendship and
the good and bad aspects of life and how
he reacts to it and it sort of comes to
a close where it so beautifully
encapsulates that sort of gives you a
sense that everything has a purpose in
life
whether it's good or bad i feel like
this book could have so easily been one
of these books where people say they
read and they they they go oh i read
suit hearth i'm so enlightened now or
something stupid but that's the whole
point of the book is that you can't get
enlightenment from just teaching or just
experience or just reaching pleasure or
pain it comes from understanding all
these things on our own our own
understanding of these things at least
that's what i think so saying that would
miss the whole point it's just a lovely
story and i highly recommend it i
recommend all these books i had a great
time reading fiction again it's been a
while since i i was into it i've
been so much on the philosophy train
that that i forgot that sometimes it's
good to balance what you read and it's
way easier to recommend these books as
well so i think anyone can pick these up
i would rate them all highly but if you
if i had to pick some i would go with
these three siddhartha if you want
something more spiritual stranger if you
haven't read anything in a while and
want to get back into reading
and if you want some non-fiction this is
a great book
i got you covered baby book review back
thanks for watching if you enjoyed
subscribe to channel more to come i
upload whatever i want on this channel
so check it out
i upload whatever
i have an amazing fanbase that lets me
upload whatever i want thank you all
right that's it see you next time
profess
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express
still emotions
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this